it was the very youngest patients at the
Countess of Chester Hospital that Lucy
letby cared for
she treated each of the seven newborns
who died in suspicious circumstances
there in 2015 and 2016.
five years into her career as a nurse
Lucy leppy was accused of murder
she told the court I don't think you can
be accused of anything worse than that
my job was my life
she broke down in tears at this point
and added my whole world just stopped
in deciding to give evidence herself
Lucy letby has chosen to directly
confront the allegations that she
murdered babies in her care she was
asked seven times in a row whether or
not she'd harmed them
her defense team asked her have you ever
tried to kill any baby you've cared for
no have you ever intentionally harmed or
tried to intentionally harm any of the
babies as alleged no never
have you ever introduced air
intravenously or forced air down a
nasogastric tube no I haven't
have you done that for the intention of
killing a baby or for any other reason
no
her denials kept coming she said she'd
never assaulted babies never overfed
them and never poisoned them with
insulin
she described how upsetting it was when
a baby died on the unit to try and
process it she would often write down
notes
in one she wrote the words I killed them
on purpose because I'm not good enough
but Lucy letby said her mental state was
not good at all when she wrote it she
said it was just her processing her
thoughts she will continue to be
questioned on Friday and denies all the
charges she faces Tom Parmenter Sky News
Manchester